le premier grand dossier social de la
rentrée avec les négociations qui
s'engage pour le passage aux 35 heures
dans le secteur hospitalier le
gouvernement propose la création de
quarante mille postes sur trois ans dans
un instant de nous recevrons d'ailleurs
elisabeth guigou la ministre de l'emploi
et de la solidarité
écoutons d'abord les premières réactions
des partenaires sociaux à cette
proposition
le reportage est signée christelle
meyrals et fabrice launay cet après midi
tous les responsables syndicaux sont
arrivés en avance pour la grande
négociation sociale de la rentrée les 35
heures dans les hôpitaux
la ministre elle est arrivé tout sourire
car elle a obtenu de lionel jospin les
arbitrages qu'elle demandait elisabeth
lindley a annoncé 40 mille emplois
supplémentaires dans les hôpitaux des
emplois créés sur trois ans
les syndicats saluent l'effort mais
selon eux cela reste insuffisant
cette base de négociation pour commencer
la discussion est quand même une base
intéressante
bien évidemment nous considérons que
c'est en incorpore au bout c'est à dire
qu'il va falloir encore faire un effort
au niveau de la création d'emplois même
si comme l'a dit la ministre c'est une
enveloppe exceptionnelle
nous considérons que cela pourrait être
encore plus exceptionnel dès que ensuite
ma soeur me françois brière et bien le
contenu et par le front tu n'y es pas
car 48 l'emploi cela correspond à 5 %
d'effectifs en plus dans les hôpitaux la
cfdt et fo réclament au minimum 58
postes
la cgt et sud vont plus loin ils
demandent 80 mille emplois 10 %
d'effectifs supplémentaires pour passer
aux 35 heures ou le monde pointe
l'hôpital comme étant le bon élève de la
maîtrise comptable des dépenses de santé
ça veut dire que sur l'hôpital qui fait
le plus d'efforts aujourd'hui les
efforts et se traduisent par un mal vie
par tout ce qu'on a eu cet été dans les
médias autour de la fuite des
professionnels on pense que la pénurie
se situe autour de 20 mille emplois
qu'on n'arrive pas à recruter au niveau
de l'hôpital
on nous dit quarante mille créations
d'emploi ça ne va pas compenser des 10%
de réduction du temps de travail
ce soir les discussions se poursuivent
deux autres rendez vous sont prévus
début septembre pour des négociations
qui s'annoncent
difficile 48 postes pour